RIP foreshadowing Twitch contract requires Emir to attend meet
and greet. Oh, is this her complaining about having to go without
private security
because we did watch some of this clip earlier. Oh, this is a
different one.
>> So, I had to cancel my meet and greet because of the
stuff, but in order it's I can't
>> uh I will also say
how much do you think this could be like a self-inflicted problem
in some way? Like, is it possible that if these people just didn't
keep referring to
how bad the security was that maybe somebody wouldn't have tried
something
like like really
all you hear is there's no security. This is way too dangerous.
There's no security
and somebody I just wonder if somebody heard that and was like,
you know what?
Let's see. I sincerely doubt it as well. Warp thing. I I >> cancel
my meet and greet and not cancel her show because of the fact
that the reason I cancel my meet and greet is I don't want to
be in the same place for two hours. >> Oh, so that's not
about security at all >> Oh, wait. No, that is about security.
>> People being weird. >> And then I'm under contract.
>> To be fair, SA was in that group with Emmy that like
nearly got stabbed by that guy or something, right? That had
that like totally unhinged stalker who followed them around the
amusement park, right? Am I crazy? Was that like Valkyrie, Emiru,
SA, and was it extra? Was it extra Emily? I forget who the fourth
was >> with them. So, I can't cancel one and not cancel
the other. >> Interesting. A
>> I kept my mean and greet cuz I wanted to keep my show.
Surely it'll be fine. >> Sorry, Emmy. >> I'm sure
everyone will be nice. >> So, I had to cancel my >> my
mean greet cuz I wanted to keep my show. Surely it'll be fine.
>> Sorry, Emmy. >> I'm sure everyone will be nice.
>> Surely that'll be fine.
Surely everyone will be nice.
Pokey. Oh, is Pokey there? Okay,
Pokey was there. Okay, cool. Maybe extra Emily wasn't there then.
Oh, that's that's kind of brutal. That's a rough one. That's
a rough one, dude. Poor Emmy. I wonder how many metos we're going
to wake up to on Monday. Difficult to say. I was kind of hoping
there'd be like a lot more on LSF from today. I figured there'
just be like way more [__] going on from these TwitchCon
like IRL streams,
but I just haven't seen much here. Oh, hold on.
Okay, I have no idea what's going on with this, but why not check
it out? Okay, Action Man's energy changed when being confronted
by heel mic completely folded. Why was Action Man getting pressed
by Heel Mike? And where is this occurring? Is this at TwitchCon?
Would this be in San Diego or is this just in Austin or some
Hello. How you doing? We're not normally weird.
>> Oh, no. This is definitely a TwitchCon. There's Nick
Wick Lee. This is definitely a TwitchCon. >> Wait, Mike.
>> Mike, where are we? Wait, Mike. >> Oh, what? What's
up? >> How you been, bro? >> I've been phenomenal.
How you been >> I've been all right, bro. >> How
you doing? >> You been good? >> I can't do that.
I've been great. I've been great. >> Come on, Mike. >> Come
on. You say crazy [__] >> You said
>> I I want to say we watched some stream where
Action Man was talking. Wasn't that with Zena or something? He
was talking. He mike
>> Yes, you did. >> No, I didn't. I just told you.
I didn't say >> what's that? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Um, yeah. Something with Lauren de Laguna, right?
>> Right. But you still you still instigated it. >> Oh
my god. >> Do you think I hate you, Mike? >> I don't
give a [__] you hating your life. That's unforgivable.
Can never go >> But you said that was unforgivable to me.
You did. >> What did I say
about your family? I didn't talk about >> Right. But you
took shots at me. I didn't know what to do. >> No, you
talked
You said things that were unforgivable, too. What did I say?
Or what did what did I say? Uh, I don't know, man. You took shots
of me, though. >> Way too reckless, bro. Way too reckless.
Way too reckless. And the fact that you're like still say all
this. >> I don't still say this.
>> Mike, what do I call you? >> Talk about crazy
>> and then and then I see you like this and that we're
cool. I'm not saying we're not going to be cool, but I'm saying
what crazy >> action man do kind of seem he does kind of
seem like the kind of guy that would have like heat off stream
and then if you met in real life, he would just not say any of
the same [__] like at all. He'd just be super nice.
>> What did I say? >> I know exactly what you said.
>> I know what I said. >> Call me two. Dude, I don't
think he'll Mike's a I watch he might get the [__]
kicked out of him by some dudes. I don't think he's a >> [__]
p even though nothing. I didn't I didn't say you were talking
about my [__] dad. >> I I did. >> Yeah,
100%. There's no morals with that, bro. No morals and no principle,
dude. >> So, I'm supposed to do what? >> How about
we admit this? John Zirka
both of us up. >> I'm good, bro. I bounce. >> No,
admit though. Admit that John [__] both of us up.
>> Wait, how did John Zirka [__] Action Man
up? Action Man makes so much money. Action Man's got such a huge
community. What? What is he even saying? >> I don't know.
I take accountability, bro. It's just as >> you weren't,
Mike. Bro, Mike, I knew you at Fortnite. >> It doesn't
matter. >> It does matter. You were totally different before
you met John, dude. >> Hell no, bro. >> You were
not count. >> Mike, I know. >> I had one dumb year
of my life. >> It was a bad year. And I'm not. But I'm
saying, but Mike, without John, you would not without John Zurker,
you never would have been banned. >> Who cares? I >> I
care back. I bounce back. I'm doing >> Okay. I'm glad you
are. >> Yeah, dude. I don't know, dude. just >> I
just feel like this [__] should have been like >> appeared
out of nowhere. I wonder if it's awkward for her to hang out
with Action Man again after all the glue factory comments. >> I
mean, bro, you said some unforgivable >> I said some [__]
up. I did because I felt you coming at me, bro. >> Oh yeah,
but you don't go that far, bro. It's principal. It's >> evil.
It's actually evil. >> So, you're saying that was evil
of me? >> All right. Well, then I'm sorry if I hurt you
like that. >> I You hurt my >> Okay. Well, I didn't
mean to I didn't mean to hurt your family, bro. But I'm saying,
but you got you sided with John Zora and I felt like I was attacked.
>> No, I didn't with nobody. >> You did, bro.
>> Mike, when we were Let me ask you a question, Mike.
When we were at N Cip's house, remember in the basement I said
>> I called John out and you weren't on my side. The main
thing is what you said. You said, >> but I said it because
like I felt you came at me, bro. >> I called you a [__]
or something like that or like [__] Oh, I have been
so lazy in the calls to action, guys. Two more hours, 60 bucks.
I totally understand if you guys aren't hitting that tonight.
All right, I totally get it. Um, I could leave the Rob stuff
for tomorrow. It looks like Rob talked about it more tonight.
So, I'll have time to to put that stuff together if we don't
hit the two hours. If we do hit the two hours, I'll continue
to look for TwitchCon highlights from all of these streamers.
And if we don't do a bunch of TwitchCon highlights, we'll end
up doing the Rob stuff. Okay, that would be what you'd be paying
for. So guys, if you like the content, you can go ahead, you
can donate, you can give subs, you can sub individually, you
can do whatever you want. All right, don't forget the Patreon.
discord.gg/jdk.
>> Man, what if these girls want to not
>> And you go, oh my god. >> Right. Okay, so I turned
off my >> dad blah blah blah. He fell down the stairs,
blah blah blah. And then >> I went crazy. >> And
then I went crazy.
>> They shouldn't have done that. They should No, I I'm
not I >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Zurka's
hanging out with Rampage Jackson at TwitchCon. Crisp, did you
just Is that what you're saying? That John Zurka is hanging out
with Rampage Jackson at TwitchCon.
I feel like those words don't go together in a sentence. Are
you sure?
Okay, but I hear you. But at the same time, you got to understand
that like >> I don't understand [__] >> Mike,
I'm going to say so. I knew you since you were playing. Mike,
you were popping as [__] on Twitch in 2019. Oh >> If
you guys >> I'm not saying you're not, but I'm saying at
that time you were one of the biggest streamers on Twitch. I
>> Dude, Action Man's such an as Holy
I I can't Action Man's like whole thing when he interacts with
other people is like trying to get punched in the face but also
be called the victim in the situation, right? Like that's that's
such an obvious dig.
And then he's like, "Yeah, I know you're still popping now, but
I'm telling you, in 2019 you were really riding high, okay? You
were really cool in 2019.
>> Remember you? >> I'm saying they were hang out
ages ago at Hunger Games. Oh, >> before you met John Zurka.
And I'm not going to sit here and have John take account for
your No, I'm not going to sit here and have John Zurka take account
for your actions. But Mike, I remember you before him and you
were a different guy, bro. >> Okay. Who gives a [__]
>> I give a still a different guy. He's not around. You
the same person. >> But look what he did to you. >> Look
what he did to me. I put myself in >> No, no, he did. And
he >> No, he didn't. Bro, what are we women who are like
>> So, you take a thousand% accountability. >> Oh,
I made stupid ass jokes and I was just as bad as him making the
dumb
>> Oh, right.
I think I remember now. Was it I I saw recently like Ice Boseidon
or Action Man talking about how badly Heal Mike himself up because
he had such an awesome gambling contract, right?
Like through stake. That was like the the comments that were
being made.
Also,
where does he even stream now? I believe he's on party, right?
He's on he's on the the party site, whatever. The one Sneo streams
on. >> You weren't just as bad as him, Mike. >> Okay.
Yes, he was worse, but I still mean we were there. >> [__]
It doesn't matter. >> We were side by side. And guess what?
I took Wait, Mike. Let me say something. When we were I didn't
say you didn't >> but when I was when we were at Nana's
house, I tried to reel us together. >> I did. You were.
>> Oh my god, bro. I don't really care. You don't care.
But I'm saying like I don't want you to sit here and blame me
for the reason why any of this [__] happened. Bro,
>> I don't blame you at all. I don't even think about you,
bro. You still talk about me. The only reason I know you talk
about me is literally people at me about it. I'm like, I don't
care, >> bro. I haven't talked about you in a while, bro.
But I mean, I did it first. It's been like 6 8 months. >> Wait,
Mike. But they don't understand her history, bro. Because >> talked
to me two weeks ago, still called me a and literally still literally
two weeks ago. >> When? literally to each other when I
ran into those dumb
>> Oh, yeah. I said that if you I said you were supposed
to walk away from the first place.
>> That time
you're right. >> We didn't know anything about that, bro.
>> Come on, man. You You But I'm saying But you knew what
my You knew what John was doing. You knew what he was doing.
>> but I'm saying But why don't you want to hold But why
don't you want to hold him accountable, though? >> Because
I'm a man. >> He [__] both of our lives up.
He's He did. I was almost [__] up by him. >> Well,
I had I've been living life and I've had 30 years of being blessed
and out of >> You have been blessed. >> You have
been one year was bad. Woohoo. Who cares?
>> Bro, we could have been so much though,
>> So, wait. It's not. But I'm saying you don't ever look
at
>> Okay. I need to know what the [__] to action
man. What What did John Zurka do to action? >> Like, we
could have been so much
>> Mike. I don't know, bro. I think you're a chameleon.
Actually, I think you really think you just blend in with who
you're with. >> Mike, you know my content isn't like that,
bro. >> I don't know, bro. You're a chameleon. >> You
really think that way?
>> I do, actually.
>> I got nothing against you, >> bro. You remember
when we were in Neon Sniper Panda's basement that one day and
we weren't agreeing and I was wondering >> I feel like
every memory you have of that you probably have that same slightly
identical emotional moment with like eight other streamers. Like
you're >> Bro, Mike, me and you were really close. Without
you, I never would have went to LA. I never would have met Jazz.
I never would have had any of the content I had. You invited
me to LA. You were Mike, if anyone's new to this, Keel Mike was
years ahead of me. when we first met. >> Still am. >> No,
no, be serious though. You were Yes or no? You were way ahead
of me. You were popping on Twitch way more than me. >> And
I always wondered like
>> when you invited me to LA, >> he's got that MV,
bro. You got to get that out of here. >> I had the MV,
>> Mike. When we went to do hot tub streams, I invited
whatsoever faces. You had a problem with >> Why? I don't
even I don't even
why these two are talking to each other. They despise each other.
It's like they both decided to stop in this corner and now the
person who leaves loses. So they're both just talking to each
other even though they both despise you. >> That that started
our beef >> M. So you don't want to admit Mike? You don't
want to admit that started our beef? Yes or no? >> Oh,
no. I don't I don't know where >> Well, if the hot tub
streams at uh Near Pan's house. >> Well, I don't care about
any beef. Just >> No, I don't either, bro. >> Too
far
>> because look, I felt I felt like we were going to be
>> Wait, look, let's end this here. But I'm saying like
I thought that like me and you were going to be boys. >> How
would we be boys? >> Not now. Right. Two weeks ago you
called me a then you see me a person and now we're supposed to
be. >> I'm not saying hey I didn't call you a two weeks
ago. I'm not saying I never did but I'm saying when I did it
was because like we were supposed to be >> Said I underage
people where I never did any of that. Everything ever called
you any of that ever happened. >> Tell your but I'm saying
though Mike tell your community I didn't. >> I dragged
you down because >> tell them tell them I didn't. You never
the girls that were underage. >> Thank you. I didn't even
[__] kiss him either. No, >> you didn't.
>> And I
circa definitely did >> saying, but if I would have been
>> also Mike definitely did. Mike's Mike's just totally
full of it. Mike had so many bits with these girls, dude. I don't
believe either of these people >> there. And I I just remember
like you and John talking to me before it
>> Oh, Zirka took Heel Mike from Action Man and he's upset.
I see.
What's up, Pugy Gups? How's it going?
How's it going, buggy cups? What's up? >> I never would
have let that happen if I was with y'all. And y'all made me seem
like I was like the problem. I was never the problem. If you
remember when we all me, you and John talked at the Panda's house.
I was trying to get us to link up, bro. I was trying to get us
on the same page, bro. >> Yeah, I know, bro. That's awesome.
>> No, I'm saying but John both of us up cuz he's influential.
I looked up to John, too. Like just how you did. >> He
was the wrong leader, bro. He was the wrong leader. Mike, I don't
think
Dude, quick action man crying meme. Okay, let's check it out
real quick. >> Take your
>> I'm trying to take the hardest of my life. I hear some
Look at me. I'm sweating my ass off. What the is this >> Harrison,
you made yourself look like a total ass and now I have a legal
>> That's cool. You
bro, you annoy.
Shut the up. Damn, dude. Annoying.
>> Hold on. Hold on. What is this Teone video I'm seeing.
I feel like Techone just made a Emmy got assaulted and I'm really
mad video. 15,000 views 1 hour ago. Look at the thumbnail. Look
at the thumbnail. I might I might have to go check this out really
quickly.
>> What the is this problem? >> Harrison, you made
yourself a total [__] and now I have a legal lawsuit.
>> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Action man was alreadyed
up at this point when he was about to cry. Chris B lettuce they
like they took him out into a field and like ran him they like
kept pushing him down on the ground. He kind of got up in a way
he never had before. Like he's sunburned. He's bitten up by bugs.
He doesn't go outside very often.
>> You annoy
the updo.
>> Yo on drugs or some [__] >> Yeah always.
That was actually why we had a >> Hey, I need to change
pants. >> Hiding behind >> you. Keep it hiding behind
real badly.
>> He's hiding behind ramping. >> Hey, I just came
out here. If you annoying this >> All right. Uh I might
have to check out this techone video. We got 43 seconds left.
I might leave it. 43 seconds, but I kind of want to lead into
the video. I think we looked at some of these Techone things.
I think I got to do the techone video real quick cuz I saw it.
Could have been content for tomorrow. If you're attending TwitchCon,
please walk out. There's many other things to do in San Diego.
It is unsafe there. Twitch staff and Dan Clemens are incompetent.
Okay. All right. All right. Rape tone. Let's Let's give it a
quick look. >> Hey guys.
>> Hey guys. >> Hopefully I can get through this
video without being uh too angry. It's midnight where I'm at.
Uh >> did you get banned from Twitch? No. Emir just got
assaulted and Tech is mad. Techone is very mad about this. I
don't I don't think he got a permanent ban. I think he got like
a twoe ban. Didn't he get like a twoe ban before? I think.
Am I crazy? Someone tell me I'm crazy right now. I think he only
got like a twoe ban.
Hold on. Uh Twitch bands techone. Let me look this up. Uh I don't
think so, but maybe it is. Unbanned after 7 days. September 2nd,
2005. Currently unbanned.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. All right.
Amiru Amiru has been defiled. Uh, burn TwitchCon down is the
is the general tone of the techone video. Okay. >> It's
midnight where I'm at.
Uh,
just started
about 3 hours ago.
I have been warning
everyone not to go.
Every single person.
I told all of my friends.
I told
all of my viewers.
I told everybody
to please not go to TwitchCon. I even you know one great conversation
that came to mind is a very at length
discussion I had with a good friend of mine Mari
and I explain I explained to him >> I explained to Rakari
>> my concern
for him going to TwitchCon and thankfully he listened as as well
as many of my viewers. >> Okay, let's be real. Lucari's
like a tank. Lucari would have been fine. Why is he in his garage?
Because he's in a brooding mood. Okay. And he didn't like the
optics of the closet. The closet was one choice he had for when
he was in a brooding mood. Now he's in a brooding mood. He wants
a black wall behind him. Okay. You guys remember the uh the closet,
the one where he talked about going to church apparently and
then goodbye Charlie when Charlie died. >> Oh no, it's
actually the same room. This is the closet. >> He just
had more dramatic lighting in whatever blackwalled closet this
is. This is like his brooding video. Okay. Something terrible
has happened. Charlie Kirk died. Emiru assaulted.
You know,
not all of my view. >> This isn't a garage. Lucas Jason.
Look at the trim. Ain't nobody putting um ain't nobody putting
trim up in a garage like this. You know, it's like a empty room
in his new house. >> You're not attending TwitchCon right
I think closet because of, you know, it's obviously a room with
all walls, possibly hardwood floors. The sound bounces a thousand
times and >> uh sorry, four walls, smaller room,
possibly hardwood floors, sound bouncing >> A lot of my
streamer friends are not going as well. Of which I will not name
because if you're friends with me, people don't like you,
which is
fun. If you haven't seen by now, the reason why I'm very angry
is because
a very good friend of mine
uh did a podcast with her with part of OTK with her, someone
who I respect very much, someone who has been very kind to me
um my entire time since I've known them.
uh streamer by the name of Emiru
got assaulted at TwitchCon
by a deranged van
on camera
in front of a crowd
with security guards there and no one prevented it. Nobody
Dan Clansancy
wants to talk about
>> I want Dancy Dancy I want Dan Clansancy held personally
liable for this. Okay, I want I want Dan Clansancy held personally
liable. Okay, hang Dan Clans. I'm just >> increased security
measures.
>> Dan Clansancy is responsible for Emir being defiled.
Okay, first he let her live with Msk and now he let her be assaulted
at TwitchCon. When will we ever see an accounting of Dan Clancy's
>> They want to talk about how this Twitchcon will be different.
And the worst thing is people look at me and they say I'm crazy
that I'm delusional
that I'm imagining things and time after
>> dude him and legal mindset somehow just keep getting
told they're crazy they're delusional they're imagining things
>> Yeah. Every time I get proof >> I I wonder if
possibly you're you're just a little hyperbolic. Maybe you sometimes
blow things out of proportion. Techone. You think
>> doesn't help
that certain streamers like Miskf
have completely obliterated my reputation for the past 4 years?
What the Has Miskf on this guy's reputation? I guess he's saying
behind the scenes, right? It's hard to speak to behind the scenes.
Maybe Miskf really has like totally obliterated Tech's reputation
behind the scenes. It's unfortunate that TeeOne did a similar
of his reputation publicly, right? Like it would be good if one
of them didn't Te's reputation, but you know they double penetrated
Teone's reputation. Misk taking the private hole, Teone taking
the public hole.
And day after day, I have to unshovel the [__] that's
been put on me due to streamers like that where people have a
harder time
listening and paying attention to the very clear warnings that
I give people because I'm a very careful individual.
I've made a couple mistakes in my life, but I really try to absorb
all the information from every angle, especially >> Why
is he whispering? Does he understand that he's alone in a house?
Like there's nobody nobody's
brother, just speak normally. When >> it comes to safety
and security, sorry if I'm a little bit different right now.
I am violent.
>> Sorry, I just saw this video down here. Emu attacks.
A little bit of a >> Emmy attacked at TwitchCon. Dan Bracket.
Dan Clancy's fault. Bracket.
Brh. Bruh. Bruh.
Do you think this guy just echoes Techone and everything? I wonder
where this guy gets cuz I just feel like the only way you say
this kind of thing is
scary situation when it comes to TwitchCon and Emu because Emu
was up on stage and she was assaulted with >> I got We'll
watch this after techone. Not this one. Not goodbye Charlie.
This one. Sorry, I'm I'm being ADHD, but what >> shaking
with anger and I'm trying to
not yell.
If you're a streamer,
if you're a viewer, leave Twitch now.
Get out.
This happened within the first 3 hours. You are not safe there.
You're just not.
>> You're not. >> This needs to be the last TwitchC
that ever happens.
They need to shut this [__] down. And to be honest,
I think they should absolutely get sued
for not being able to ensure
the safety of the streamers when they say, "Hey, come meet this
streamer right here." Cuz you want to know why it's so bad, guys?
I think it's a little crazy that um if they if the streamers
hire their own additional private security and they the private
security needs to get rid of somebody that the private security
would get banned from the venue, right? That's probably a pretty
good criticism. Like there should be no reason that you ban their
private security from protecting them if you aren't going to
give like over overwhelming security to some of these people,
right? Like Emirus one who's had like a lot of stalker problems
and and courts that exact audience probably all of those OTK
girls. Extra Emily,
Extra Emily. I don't think Sin is in OTK or I don't know, but
her uh Emiru and who was the fourth one that was there with them.
I lost it. >> One of the worst >> Valkyrie was there
with them the other time. I meant um in the clip today. Who's
in the trip with them? They're going on a trip. start.
>> had a security guard
two years ago
that attended TwitchCon
where another fan was attempting to assault her and this >> Bonnie.
Okay. security guard stopped him, but because Twitch Twitch staff
Twitch official staff didn't agree with the way that he that
he stopped him, which by the way was just him putting his hands
on him and making it to where he couldn't leave while the police
they permanently
banned him
from ever being a part of TwitchCon again. So the security guard
that did their job to make sure that Emmy was safe
was banned.
Meaning the fault of this lies entirely on Dan Clancy's head
and Twitch's head.
I want to speak directly
to Dan right now. You are a >> Dan Clancy. Listen to me
now. the food.
You are a [__]
You can't moderate your own site.
You think that you can moderate a live event?
The the security around there is a >> You haven't even
banned
any of the pro Palestine people. You haven't even banned Hassan
for torturing his dog on stream. And you think you can protect
>> Really, Dan? Can a man with no morals really protect
Emmy? >> Is it possible? >> I want to remind you
NMP and >> Oh, this would have been a great idea. Hold
on. Hold on. Yeah, we should have we should have thrown some
music up in his background here for sure. Hold on. No, this is
totally true. >> Wilder were also assaulted by a fan last
year. You were letting streamers >> They weren't insulted
by a fan. They were sexually assaulted by a provocator who went
there to provoke people. >> Run a mug. push other streamers
into
moving trains and you did nothing. >> Sorry, this is just
going to fit better
>> of one of my viewers
getting hurt
because you won't just admit your
drives me insane.
You run defense and actively
>> and if you admitted that you were wrong for one of your
past decisions, that means you would obviously do a better job
at security at this event.
a terrorist supporter,
a guy who has >> if you didn't promote Hassan [__]
a terrorist supporter, then I know that Emir could have been
protected. Emir could have absolutely we could have relied on
your protection if you only would have disavowed us >> his
viewers
to kill people in the streets. Twitch, I'm not sure if you're
even aware of this, but he's currently dog whistling for his
audience to me right now and you're doing nothing.
Now, I would like to make it very clear. I'm not afraid. I can
deal with whatever comes my way. I'm not worried about me. I'm
worried about other people.
Because you're allowing this to continue, this behavior to continue.
You pick and choose favorites for who you want to ban or unban.
Let us not forget I got banned for two weeks for calling Froa
the fat
>> you guys just let me call Frogan fat.
Emir might still be with us today.
She's not dead, but her spirit is. >> I got banned for
two weeks for Denims. The person who believes that intellect
is transmitted by how many dudes she sucks. The >> Who's
Wait, what? That intellect is transmitted by how many dudes she
sucks the day.
>> What
the just say? >> The person fat.
I got banned for two weeks for denims. The person who believes
that intellect is transmitted by how many dudes she sucks the
dick of. >> Intellect is transmitted by how many dudes
she sucks the dick of. That's actually John Zurka and it does
have to do with embibing seed. Yeah, that is a thing that John
Zurka believes 100%.
Um, yeah. No, that's I don't know. I I confuse them all the time,
too. Okay. Denim TV, John Zurka, basically the same philosophies
in life. >> God, they were two weeks ago or a whole and
these people falsely accuse me of being a and you've let it go
on for years.
The amount of complete baseless lies you allow to be slung towards
me, towards my friends like Asmold,
Knox, just to name a few issu
known degenerate who is now trying to signal some traditional
values in order to ingratiate himself to this Asmin Gold adjacent
audience that is massive and has zero brain cells. Okay, call
Knucks whatever you want. No name for Nuaku is too far. Okay,
call him anything you want. He is not somebody who should be
given human
>> You are a joke of a platform. And by the way, when I
do come back to streaming,
>> and that has nothing to do with him being Israeli, by
the way. That's totally disconnected. Just so you know, just
throwing it out there. >> I could say
Twitch, not going to stream there. I'm gonna make sure that I
stream there every time to let your viewers know live that your
website is a piece of
and make sure to convert as many people off that platform to
somewhere else.
>> I cannot believe
it has been 3 hours
and something awful has already happened.
Guys, you're in San Diego. Do something else.
Go to the zoo.
Go hang out at Round One. Go to an arcade. Go hit some, you know,
a bar.
Go to one of the content creators like houses and just chill
there at TwitchCon. You are not saying. >> Yes. Guys, can
you believe that a website that feeds off of Paris,
>> bro? I listen, let's just be real.
Who thinks the guy who did this? Okay, we go look at this guy's
follows. We look at the guy who did this. What are the odds that
he doesn't follow TeeOne very closely?
I I'm going to go out I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say there's a 0% chance that this guy is not a devout follower
and tier five sub to Tee. Okay, there's a 100% chance of that.
He is Tee's biggest fan. Obviously, he is doing as his favorite
content creator does, not as he says. their socials
and then they say, "Hey,
>> just kidding. That's mostly a joke. Just a little just
a little joke, guys. We watched that big bungee video. We're
getting a little unhinged." All right, that's just a joke.
I I listen
I there's probably only a 50% chance that's true. >> Hey,
uh all these women that you think that you're dating because
you're tier three subbing to them. Uh yeah, you can just go meet
them in person. Oh. Uh, and we banned all the good security guards
cuz they did their [__] jobs. What
>> I mean genuinely what the
>> Make sure you guys go and uh
express your anger
towards this.
TwitchCon would be great. # Twitch
#fired Dan Clancy would be great because an injustice like this
cannot go
There is no way.
This is
This is disgusting. I am beyond furious that such a simple issue
could have been solved if Twitch got their head out of their
ass and did the right thing for [__] once. But they
didn't. They fired the security guard because he did his job.
And this is what happened. Twitch, you're [__] with
the wrong people and you're promoting
the wrong
And and it's at this level that I have to assume that what you're
doing is
You guys intentionally
got Emirou assaulted. What was the purpose of this? Why would
you have this intent? I can't possibly say, but I believe you,
Dan Clansancy, personally wanted Emiru, okay, at TwitchCon, according
to
Amazing, amazing stuff. >> And it sucks because I feel
guilt
because maybe I should have warned people more.
Maybe I should have tried harder to get people to not go.
But you know what they always do? Move on, bro. >> All
I think about now is did I work hard enough to tell them not
to go to TwitchCon? Was it my fault?
How culpable am I in this defiling of Emiru that has happened?
Guys, that's what I think about when I when I see Emirus insulted.
I just think about me. Me.
>> Oh, nobody cares.
This guy's delusional.
Uh, this guy's still going on about this. Well, guys, I stayed
consistent with what I was saying about Hassan. And thankfully
today, he had a full-on mental breakdown on stream because that
guy's a piece of
and that's what happens when I'm allowed to remain consistent.
So to all of those who don't mind me beating a
>> Is that the political rant Hassan went on? That's like
basically a political rant he goes on
every month. I don't know. I guess he goes back and forth. Okay.
He does go back and forth between being like that's blackpilled
and then I'm blackpilled. But that's blackpilled and I I try
to remain hopeful but that I'm so blackpilled. Guys,
>> thank you because at least some type of progress happen.
talk about dant
because at least some type of progress happens
bad things happen to good people.
Stay safe out there, guys. >> It does not feel good to
say I told you so again. I take no joy in this. I hate
>> It's really >> the whisper. Okay. The forecaster.
This guy. This guy knew it would happen. Okay.
He knew. And he just he's he's
Cassandra. All right. He can put out the warnings, but he can't
make these women protect themselves.
Okay,
>> Twitch man. Okay, a little bit. Listen, I don't want
to say that Teone's correct. Also, we should watch this video
like we said we're going to. But I will I will say Twitch's response
seems a little weak. They basically came out and said, "Oh, guess
what, guys? Uh, we fired the the security guard who failed to
protect Emiru."
It's like, okay, seems like there were a lot of issues there.
Like how about the fact that two of the security guards were
like petite women who probably would never have stopped that
guy. Even if both of them were in perfect position to try to
block that guy, he would have shed. Dude, that
that guy was massive. That guy was like, he was huge. There's
no way those two tiny women were stopping him from getting to
Emirou, right?
Maybe there's some bigger issues than just it's not DI. That's
not what I'm saying. I'm just saying maybe there's some bigger
issues like possibly your approach to private security that have
been a problem.
No, there was a third security guard there who was a man. He
was talking to a woman, Chris let us. And then there was a woman
who was at the front of the line letting people in to take pictures
and then she was taking pictures herself. That might not have
been security. I'm not 100% sure. But there Twitch statement
on recent safety concerns. We're aware of the incident involving
streamer Emir. Oh, hold on. Don't do the cringe music for me.
just do the cringe soy music for techone. Okay. Uh, we're aware
of the incident involving streamer Emiru during TwitchCon and
want to assure our community that we take creator safety extremely
seriously. The individual responsible for allowing the situation
to occur has been removed from their position effective immediately.
We're conducting a full review of our security protocols and
are implementing stronger on-site safety measures to ensure TwitchCon
remains a safe and positive environment for everyone, creators,
fans, and staff alike. Thank you for your patience and understanding
as we work to improve the TwitchCon experience moving forward.
Bro, all I can think is
at least Emiru had somebody who could knock people off of her.
Amaranth was out there on a island. You guys remember when we
looked at Amaranth stream? Amaranth was there by herself with
like nobody within 100t of her for so long. Dude, look at this.
Look at this
>> She's sitting here. No, ain't nobody even close.
We got what? One guy lurking. Nick was Amaran security. Nick
[__] off. >> Yeah, you do. >> Nick is
gone.
>> Oh, never mind. Nick's not gone. But Nick Nick is >> This
is Nick, by the way. >> Trying to think. I wanted to >> outfit.
Let's go. >> What kind of pose I wanted to do?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Nick's Nick is around kind of get you to
take us out cuz I'm a very
Okay, let's check out this uh let's check out this video.
Emiru attacked at TwitchCon. Dan Clansy's fault.
Lieutenant from a crazy fan, some lunatic in the crowd who thinks
the world revolves around him, who thinks that the world is his
for the taking when in reality he is a loser. He is a loser that
goes up and assaults people that he's never met before. when
you care so little when people care so little about your opinion
that you cut yourself off in the edit in the editing room. Okay,
you literally are just like, "No, shut the [__] up,
loser. Wait, that's me, my own. I'm shooting this video." [__]
And I 100% blame TwitchCon for this incident because several
streamers, many streamers, most streamers warned TwitchCon and
the Twitch staff about how there's crazy fans who watch Twitch,
how there's crazy people who take everything so seriously, who
just safety concerns just in general when it comes to Twitch.
And they did. They did nothing. No clear bad policies, no bigger
security, no nothing. They just did absolutely nothing. And take
>> Wait, this guy looks like the attacker.
>> for example, she had a favorite security guard from
last year who protected her >> two years ago >> from
being assaulted then. And guess what happened to that security
guard? He got fired and not allowed to come back to the venue.
All because he put his hands on >> I mean I don't think
he got fired. I I'm sure Emir hired him for other stuff. That
was her private security guard. This guy's so outraged about
Emiru getting assaulted that he's just making things up. >> Someone
who was trying to assault EU last year. Personally, I don't think
there should be any more TwitchCons. I don't think there should
be any more big streamer events when it comes to meeting people
at the public because there are so many crazy like I don't want
to say schizophrenic people because I'm schizophrenic and I don't
do this. There have always been schizophrenic people. This has
always been a concern. I'm pretty sure fans have always tried
[__] like this. Has this guy ever looked at another
country where there's like idol culture?
Bro, thank God that you're not in Japan. I feel like I've heard
about three different Japanese Tik Tok streamers and getting
carved up in the past year. Like literally just them following
them on some IRL stream, stabbing them on the side of a mountain
and stuffing them into a suitcase. Is that not a thing I heard
about like two weeks ago? Some Japanese streamer getting stuffed
into a suitcase on the side of a mountain?
Tell me. I'm not I'm not hallucinating, right? had happened.
There are schizophrenics everywhere. You should have security,
but like this has always been the case. Did you miss him calling
himself skits? I did. >> He put his hands on someone who
was trying to assault Emeru last year. Personally, I don't think
there should be any more TwitchCons. I don't think there should
be any more big streamer events when it comes to meeting people
with the public because there are so many crazy like I don't
want to say schizophrenic people because I'm schizophrenic and
I don't do this sort of thing. So, I don't think being schizophrenic
is an excuse to go attack people who you see on the internet.
Oh, it's definitely a te techone viewer. Another person who's
wearing schizophren
let's take a look. What do you guys think? Technone fan. Big
te fan. Insane miskfest allegations. 9 hours ago. Is it over?
Wait, what? Bro, what?
Oh, this guy's this guy's making a new channel. Oh, how long
has this channel been around for? Oh, no. He's had big views
before. Okay, let's see here.
All right. Software situation.
We get some This is like a new thumbnail, by the way. One to
two people just It's over. It's bad. It's over. It's bad.
This is very much slop tuber stuff that that works and is effective.
I don't see an overt techone sympathy here. Anti-Hassan stuff.
Sure.
Can't say he's a techone fan over Asmin Gold though. Okay. Not
yet. Insane Hassan crash out on Ray allegations.
Okay. who you see on camera and say, "Oh, that's my favorite
person. That's my like I don't think schizophrenia is an excuse
for that because like >> like it it doesn't correlate,
but it's just people who are unwell." But I don't know. I blame
TwitchCon. I just want to spread the news of it because >> Does
he think when people say skitso, they literally mean schizophrenic?
That's not That's not really on the internet, okay? That's not
really what they mean, okay? >> It's quite frankly just
disturbing that people are like this. But if you like what you
saw, make sure you like and subscribe and thank you for watching.
Till next time, see you later.
>> Okay, hold on. Watch you back at another link for us.
What was this?
Ron, this is um this be >> stable Ronaldo, right? >> [__]
that. >> Yeah, it's stable Ronaldo.
>> [__] disgusting.
This [__] >> bro. What is security doing, bro?
I just walked up on her.
Kill that guy.
>> I can't get away with that. If I was on Twitch, there's
no shot I'd get away with that. Surely this is a Surely we'll
see Teeone and all these other people point out that this guy
just said we should kill this dude on a platform that's extremely
sensitive to violent to any uttering of violent threats and and
complain about the unfair
application of the toos. Right. >> Where's his face going?
>> Send me a screenshot of his face. I'll get him right
now. I'm not kidding. >> Okay, never mind. That was that
was way crazier. I'm sure Jason or whoever appreciates you doing
this on their stream. Jason's definitely live, right? I think
I saw Jason live earlier.
That's one of those things where it's like, "Hey buddy, fire
up your stream. You want to say that [__] Don't come
on my stream and say that. Fire up yours. You
[__] you doing, bro?" All right.
That's pretty crazy. All right. Where are we going? What are
we doing? I think that might be it for the day here, guys.
That might be it. We might be done. Thank you very much for being
here, everybody. W stream. We'll be back tomorrow.
Thank you very much for all the support.
Uh yeah, I'm going to look into that Rob Nor thing. Hold on.
Hold on. On the way out, just as a little teaser for tomorrow,
okay, let me go to Pisco's Twitter and just grab that Rob Nor
video. We'll just do this on the way out. Little little quick
teaser. Okay, for this for this content for tomorrow. I do want
to look into this. I think it should be funny. >> I do
not do that. And that's not what I'm saying when I say I'm above
these people. I'm not. >> This is Rob Nor talking about
panel >> I'm making a claim I'm smarter than them. I'm
making a claim that I have proven myself through these debates
and my ability to have serious debates that I don't need the
[__] Jerry Springer show. I don't need it.
[__] him. I don't give a anymore. [__]
you, Sarah. You Jerry Springer host
You suck.
You're garbage. Your moderating skills suck. The truth is you
like Dusty, so you're going to kiss his ass. That's the truth.
No one's intimidated by you and your creatants.
You're garbage.
That's the truth. You coward
send in DMs. Let me give you some unsolicit advice. Here's some
unsolicit advice for you. Learn to do your job as a moderator
before you criticize anyone else. How's that?
Understand? Uh he's talking to we've watched a couple of her
debate panel shows including one with counterpoints
including one with counterpoints and
Rob on it. It's this like Sarah the raging tomato person. You
guys remember this these panel shows? She does these fairly often
where we got a Rob one. Rob or counter points on one of these.
In any case, it'll be like one of these panel. Oh, it's members
only. What? Show me videos, bro. I'm just trying to show who
this channel is so people understand
>> that if >> Yeah. Yeah. It's this person. She runs
a lot of panels and debates apparently late at night.
>> All right. That's who Rob's talking about. Understand
that you rely on the talent of others for your channel
At least with Radical Coder or Dusty, they're the ones doing
the work for their channels. Albeit if they're successful or
not. But not you. So don't come at me with your h the problem
is, you know, you take things too seriously and blah blah blah.
Hey, have a laugh, [__] Have a laugh about it. Don't
take this too seriously, you loser. Right. It's all for yucks.
We're laughing it up. We're having all right. So that's I listen
how similar it is to Chank. It is a little bit like Chank. It
is.
Hold on. Let me uh I'll pull one one last clip from Crisp, then
we're going to go. Then we got to go. All right. All right, that's
it.
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Going anywhere, [__]
Get the [__] out of my neighborhood.
>> You go. >> It is actually a little bit close.
Okay, it is a little bit. I see it. I can see >> Get the
this guy. All right, I'm going to I'm going to head out. Uh Chris,
it looks like Crisp is live. I'll just host Crisp. Okay, I'll
talk to you guys later. Have a good night, everybody. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.